e as pessoas mostra é tão diferente
assim eu falando as coisas não é porque
às vezes não consigo identificar o texto
tá aqui eu falei Conversa rapaz o cara
conversa assim estamos conversando valeu
e ignorado bem pouquinho ele falou sou
pouco ignorante deveria ser mais falei
égua macho ele falou é igual hoje régua
faz tempo que ele tá fazendo de bom você
Diego e aí eu vi os cara não entendi eu
não entendi você tá chegar para mim
falar aí mano firmeza hoje vou dormir na
tua casa tá pode pá falei pode pão Olha
lá em casa pode Machado rastel inchado
não vai poder papo leve meu amigo era
sua esposa leva sofá é lógico que pode
pá até hoje demora só se aquela música
eu te avisei novinha pode pá eu falei
com ela ela tá namoro com pedreiro O que
foi agora daqui achava que eu falava
errado e eu achava que agora daqui
falava errado mas não é cara isso aí é a
diferença eu vou descer Brasil inteiro
fazendo show cara eu vejo diferença em
todo lugar que eu vou eu fiz sono da
Bahia o cara depois do show chegou para
mim falou pôrra Nego você é barril
dobrado viu velho carai tô gordo viu tô
parecendo um barril